all right we have major developments
tonight from the Muller witch-hunt
here's what you need to know first a
special counsels memo on Paul Manafort
is out it is too heavily redacted we do
know however that Robert Muller believes
that Paul Manafort breached his plea
deal and lied to investigators all
surrounding alleged crimes none of which
have anything to do with President Trump
none of which have to do with Russia or
anything to do with collusion instead a
source with knowledge of the
investigation tonight telling Fox News
that much of the redacted information
likely includes potential criminal
allegations we are told against Tony
Podesta that would be John Podesta's
brother Democratic lobbyist John Podesta
of course the Clinton campaign chair
absolutely nothing now we're talking
about in the metaphor case tax evasion
other charges bank loan applications
dating back to 2007 White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders issued this
statement it said quote the government's
filing in mr. Madoff Ford's case has
absolutely nothing about the president
it says even less about collusion it is
devoted almost entirely to lobbying
related issues and I'll add long before
Paul Manafort ever met Donald Trump and
also breaking today two separate
sentencing memos were filed against
one-time Trump attorney Michael cone
first the Southern District of New York
completely rejecting cones pleas for
leniency writing the quote a substantial
term of imprisonment is warranted then
the memo continues Cohn's decision to
plead guilty rather than seek a pardon
for his many poll crimes does not make
him a hero in exchange for combs guilty
plea the prosecutors recommended only a
slight reduction to the suggested
five-year prison sentence and meanwhile
the next memo from the special counsel
well that focused on cone admitting that
he lied under oath to the federal
government writing quote the sentence
imposed should reflect the fact that
lying to federal investigators in fact
has real consequences let's be clear the
one thing that these two filings have in
common nothing to do with Russia or
collusion at all zero evidence in any of
these documents of Trump Russia
collusion zero and today the
and he applauded the ruling he tweeted
quote totally clear as the president
thank you
and the president's attorney Rudy
Giuliani called these findings quote
complete exoneration of the president
they have nothing we are very happy
about it
and president and Giuliani the write
about this legal scholar Alan Dershowitz
very passionate tonight echoing a lot of
these sentiments including by the way
saying don't ever think about making a
deal with Muller cuz it's not gonna work
out too well for you take a look right
now it does not sound like it's good
news from Butler it doesn't sound like
in Cohen they have found a witness that
will give them the key to the kingdom so
far the only solid evidence that he has
provided is the campaign contribution
issue and it's a very very weak case oh
say tonight we have two men facing years
behind bars a third George papadopolis
was released from prison today after
serving his 12 day sentence for lying to
Muller's investigators meanwhile we had
earlier in the week American hero
Michael Flynn while he pled guilty to
lying to investigators and will become a
convicted felon but only after his
reputation and his finances were totally
destroyed and the question is for what
when you read these documents we hear
about taxi medallions fraudulent loan
applications applications tax evasion
lying about a potential project in
Moscow that never got off the ground and
whether they stopped talking about it in
January in 2016 or June in 2016
Wow the horror how will America ever
recover clearly an election was stolen
by all this information after months of
intense investigations millions and
millions and millions of your dollars
spent CD perjury traps legal coercion we
have absolutely no evidence of any
wrongdoing by the President of the
United States and then you ask yourself
this question do you feel safer tonight
do you feel safer that a low-level
campaign volunteer
he spent his 12 days in jail for
allegedly lying to the omnipotent Robert
Muller do you feel safer that American
military hero Lieutenant General Flynn
that he had to sell his house to pay his
legal
be legal bills oh the thanks one gets
for thirty-three years of service to his
country five of those years in combat by
the way neither Comey McCabe's struck or
anybody in the FBI thought he lied
but of course they put the screws to
general Flynn and he had to compose a
lie about lying and he did it to protect
his family and to get out of the mess
economically that they were putting him
in do you feel any safer tonight that
Michael Cohen is going to go to prison
for a significant amount of time let's
see for lying to Congress lying on a
bank loan application taxi medallion
loans not paying taxes do you feel safer
knowing that manna fort might spend the
rest of his life behind bars because of
again tax fraud and lies on loan
applications had nothing to do with
Russia years before he met Trump do you
feel safer than everyone surrounding the
president is seemingly targeted and
those on the Left get away every single
day scot-free is that the America we
want to live in take for example fired
FBI director James Comey and what we
learned this week about him the hills
John Solomon reporting we now have email
chains to prove that Comey and others in
Obama's DOJ that they actually knowingly
committed fraud on a FISA Court and they
used Hillary Clinton's bought and paid
for phony Russian dossier the bulk of
the evidence in their FISA applications
in their case to obtain a warrant to spy
on a trump campaign associate by the
name of Carter page well they did all of
this we learned this week knowing full
well that the Intel community did not
trust the contents of Hillary's bought
and paid Russian dossier in other words
they knowingly committed fraud on the
FISA courts not once not twice not three
but four times where's that
investigation into Jim Comey and Sally
Yates and rod Rosenstein and everybody
else that signed on to those FISA
applications giving judges fraudulent
unverified uncorroborated Russian lies
not telling the judges that it was
directly paid for by the opposition
party candidate to spy on an opposition
party
so today Comey testified behind closed
doors on Capitol Hill
his attorneys allegedly ran cover
him and prevented him from answering any
tough questions and during a subsequent
press conference arrogantly he's
brushing off any charges that his FISA
Court conduct was wrong and illegal and
disgusting but I want you to think of
this remember he's the guy that signed
on to that first warrant that was in
October 2016
but that means he had to verify it was
true that meant he verified it that mean
he corroborated that corroborated it
that means he's standing behind it but
yet in January at Trump Tower
he told Donald Trump then
president-elect that it was salacious
and unverified watch this a total
confidence that the FISA process was
followed and that the entire case was
handled in a thoughtful responsible way
by DOJ and the FBI I think the notion
that FISA was abused here is nonsense
not even Christopher Steele believes his
own dossier and he's still defending it
the bulk of information used to get
warrants to spy on Americans is that a
little more important tonight
I would think it is we all know that
dossier was and is a debunk lie Comey
never verified it nobody verified it
nobody corroborated Steele's so-called
evidence Steve steel himself wouldn't
stand by it
when questioned under oath in an intern
araga Tory down in Great Britain even
after it was used to obtain a FISA
warrant even when he said it was
salacious and unproven months after they
had the FISA warrant in place and James
Comey I guess he'll sleep well tonight
knowing that our two-tiered justice
system will likely never hold him
accountable so till will these Liars
people that lied under oath well Michel
cones in trouble tonight because of it
what about Cheryl Mills or OMA Abidine
or Bruce or or Glenn Simpson Christopher
Steele James clapper John Brennan Andrew
McCabe Lois Lerner Loretta Lynch Eric
Holder yeah all those lied to
authorities they were never prosecuted
never even investigated in many cases
and let's not forget about James Comey
remember he lied to Congress under oath
but I doubt he'll get the cone treatment
tonight and then you have the king and
queen of corruption Bill and Hillary
Clinton from mishandling top-secret
classified information obstructing
justice what the leading subpoenaed
emails acid washing hard drive
with bleach pit busting up hammer by
hammers devices phones and and
blackberries leveraging their political
positions in order to rake in millions
of dollars the Clinton's tonight or
perhaps this country's most corrupt
politicians and they have never ever
ever been held accountable but that
might be about to change John Solomon
breaking news right here on this program
last night
federal authorities received
whistleblower information in 2017
alleging that the Clinton Foundation of
a whole bunch of wrongdoing congressman
mark meadows has confirmed that the
whistleblowers have in fact turned her
over hundreds of foundation documents to
lawmakers and potentially now shedding
light into the Clinton's cloud of
corruption we're talking about
information surrounding quid pro quo
promises made to big donors while
Hillary Clinton was Secretary of State
and the commingling of funds with the
foundation and the Clintons private
money and so much more including one
glaring example when Hillary Clinton is
Secretary of State
remember this deal signed off on sending
20% of our uranium the foundational
material for nuclear weapons the
Vladimir Putin and by the way this
occurred as the Clinton Foundation was
receiving millions and millions of
dollars from the chairman of uranium one
and all the banks involved now think
about this we knew that Putin had an
operative operatives inside the United
States William Campbell was a spy within
that network identifying bribery
extortion kickbacks and money laundering
and guess what
Robert Muller was the FBI director and
in the end Putin not only got the
foothold into our uranium market the
deal happened and none of those people
got in trouble but the Clintons got
their money they got the kickback to the
foundation in terms of millions of
millions of dollars so tonight an
investigation we now know as of
yesterday is ongoing and I've said over
and over it is time in America we care
about our constitutional republic that
we end a two-tier justice system that we
have equal application of our laws and
equal justice under the law and now we
do have more good news a federal judge
just today agrees with me
judge Royce
Lamberth who's overseeing judicial
watches Freedom of Information Act
lawsuit that involves Hillary's secret
server email saga they dropped a major
bomb shell this week about just how far
the government is willing to go to skirt
transparency laws writing quote at best
the state's attempt to pass off its the
efficient search as legally adequate
during settlement negotiations was
negligence born out of incompetence at
worst career employees in the state and
Justice Department's colluded to scuttle
public scrutiny of Clinton skirt FOIA
Freedom of Information Act and hoodwink
this court and he didn't stop there
calling the Clinton email of Farrell
quote one of the gravest modern offenses
to government transparency this judge
has now ordered additional fact-finding
in the case but this is massive news and
we'll continue to keep you updated